papillon l'est demain à 23h45 sur public
sénat bienvenue dans parlement hebdo 45
minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
bonjour michael joe cocker et cette
semaine finie les couacs en série sur
les rogues sur la fiscalité l'exécutif
reprend en main la communication du
gouvernement conseil des ministres
enregistré demande d'autorisation avant
de parler l'elysée et matignon recadre
les ministres une semaine marquée aussi
par la polémique sur les rythmes
scolaires séance de questions très
agitée à l'assemblée colère des maires
de droite comme de gauche l'opposition
dénoncent une réforme injuste et mal
financé le ministre vincent peillon est
dans le collimateur et puis le plus de
parlement hebdo notre séquence politique
fiction cette semaine pleins feux sur
les femmes au pouvoir plonger dans
l'univers de borgen la série danoise qui
cartonne et puis la saison 2 des hommes
de l'ombre actuellement en tournage
d'anne frank scénaristes de la série
nous rejoindra à la fin de cette édition
et pour commenter toute cette actualité
fabienne keller bonjour bonjour
sénatrice ump du bas-rhin vice
présidente de la commission des finances
où avait été maire de strasbourg c'était
en 2001 et vous êtes en lice en piste en
tout cas pour cette prochaine élection
municipale de mars prochain
question très simple si jamais
strasbourg retomber dans votre
escarcelle dans l'escarcelle de la
droite
est ce que vous diriez que l'ump aura
gagné les élections municipales
non mon premier objectif c'est de faire
rayonner strasbourg et d'épauler les
habitants alors bien sûr ce serait une
victoire politique
c'est une grande ville c'est une
capitale l'autre capitale la capitale
européenne
et puis strasbourg c'est aussi une
mosaïque de quartier avec des
entrepreneurs mais des personnes qui
vivent en difficulté nombreux aussi
beaucoup de jeunes une ville
universitaire bref c'est une mission
passionnante que de coordonner une
équipe au service des habitants
rendez vous dans six mois en attendant
déroule le fil de la semaine et lundi
fabienne keller on parle du dimanche
qui peu ou pas travailler le dimanche le
sujet ressurgi après les fronts des
enseignes castorama et leroy merlin qui
ont ouverts illégalement le gouvernement
s'empare du dossier pour le confier
finalement à une mission chargée de
réfléchir à un aménagement de la loi
ravi car ils ont tous répondu à la
convocation
les quatre ministres concernés réunis
autour de jean marc ayrault après la
fronde des magasins de bricolage deux
heures de huis clos plus tard le
communiqué de presse de matignon tombe
le premier ministre y rappelle que le
repos dominical est un principe
essentiel à la fois de protection des
salariés de cohésion sociale cependant
le ministre demande des clarifications
et s'en remet à jean paul bailly pour
résoudre ce casse-tête juridique
la réglementation est complexe et chaque
branche a ses spécificités
par exemple les commerces alimentaires
peuvent ouvrir jusqu'à 13 heures les
fleuristes les jardineries les bureaux
de tabac et les magasins d'ameublement
peuvent eux ouvrir toute la journée pour
tous les autres depuis 2009 la loi
maillé s'applique elle instaure des
zones où l'ouverture des magasins le
dimanche est autorisée ce sont les puces
les périmètres d'usagé de consommation
exceptionnel ce sont des zones de plus
d'un million d'habitants
on y compte aussi les zones touristiques
de plus les mères peuvent accorder des
autorisations exceptionnelles cinq fois
par an les préfets eux peuvent octroyer
des dérogations individuelles pour
raisons économiques
seulement ces dérogations font souvent
l'objet de recours en justice pour
concurrence déloyale des incohérences
que le gouvernement devrait régler sans
heurter les syndicats selon le parti
socialiste
c'est un sujet qui concerne le travail
et sur toutes les questions liées au
travail
la première chose c'est les partenaires
sociaux ça passe d'abord par la
concertation les magasins qui bravent
l'interdiction d'ouverture risque d'une
amende de 120 mille euros par dimanche
travaillé
fabienne keller comment comment ça se
passe chez vous dans le bas rhin est ce
qu'il ya des dérogations qui peut pas
travailler le dimanche et est ce que
surtout c'est aussi la cacophonie
alors effectivement il ya un débat comme
partout en france même si nous avons des
textes de locaux qui complète la
réglementation nationale
je crois qu'il faut être très
pragmatique sur ce sujet on vit aussi le
dimanche donc il ya une attente de
services certains sont d'ailleurs depuis
longtemps autorisé mais le rythme
le rythme de vie partagée est important
et un jour de repos commun basse et des
rencontres familiales dès les matchs de
sport des enfants qui peuvent être
suivis par les parents on conçoit ça
c'est un débat de société la sondage
ifop 71% des français prêts à travailler
le dimanche 69 pour l'ouverture des
magasins
alors qu'il fait et 52 il ya encore
quelques mois on voit que l'opinion est
en train de changer là aussi oui puis
qu'on est tout simplement les faits de
société c'est à dire à la fois on est
heureux de pouvoir retrouver nos amis
parce qu'ils ont le même jour de repos
que nous et puis c'est bien confortable
de pouvoir faire une course où donc est
toute la question c'est autoriser le
travail le dimanche mais dans des
proportions limitées et pour des
services correspondants un mieux vivre
ensemble
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la
mission d'information qui a été demandé
à jean paul bailly par le gouvernement
est ce que vous leur demandez aux gens
de faire un choix très clair où
justement de faire du cas par cas de
d'être très pragmatique par exemple à
strasbourg on a une grande zone
touristique c'est difficile le dimanche
d'accepter que trop de commerces soient
fermés il s'agit de les accueillir mais
par ailleurs banaliser le dimanche
serait une catastrophe en termes de lien
social est à nouveau de rythme dans la
ville il ne faut pas être trop rigide
mais il faut des rythme partager à cet
égard la comparaison européenne est
intéressante parce que les pays ont
adopté différents dispositifs je crois
que c'est en allemagne qu'il y a dit
dimanche qui peuvent être ouverts en
fonction des situations locales
justement mais en allemagne les
un des canons n'eussent pas forcément
comme ils le font en france delà de leur
pouvoir de blocage d'opposition est ce
qu'à votre avis il ne faut pas sur ce
type de sujet des accords de branche
probablement des accords de branche ou
même des accords locaux en fonction des
rythmes de vie locale comme ça va nous
faire chez vous à serait absolument moi
je pense qu'il faut être très terrain et
reconnaître la dimension économique du
commerce n'est pas ouvrir pas
désorganiser une vie sociale qui est
quand même calé sur un jour de repos par
semaine alors pas si sûr à notre sujet
vous connaissez bien les centristes
fabienne keller a seulement et
jean-sylvain elle avait obtenu la
journée parlementaire vous savez qu'il y
a en ce moment rapprochement entre
françois bayrou
quels gens lui bordeaux a pour l'instant
la noce se passe pas trop mal en tout
cas les termes du contrat ne sont plus
difficiles à mettre en place des
explications de françois goulard
voilà une petite année que lui dei a vu
le jour
alors cette journée parlementaire c'est
l'occasion de faire le bilan mais c'est
surtout l'union avec le modem qui occupe
tous les esprits
si les deux baies bayrou et borloo ont
multiplié les préparatifs de fiançailles
ces dernières semaines le mariage n'est
pas encore consommée d'ailleurs presque
aucun parlementaire modem les venues
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'alliance est engagée elle
n'est pas encore scellé il reste à
l'inscrire dans l'arbre à rédiger un
papier très clair sur nos engagements et
notre positionnement donc aujourd'hui il
est logique que l'on soit dans un
rassemblement des parlementaires de
l'udps et mais sur le fond tout le monde
est d'accord le centre doit s'unir face
au gouvernement quitte à en oublier les
années de querelles passées
le modem qui avait soutenu françois
hollande considère que c'est pas
possible que que ce que
ils sont pas au rendez vous des réformes
et qui sont maintenant dans l'opposition
si c'est dans l'opposition c'est pour
construire un projet j'imagine
et donc si c'est le cas le différend que
nous avions ou la différence que nous
avions elle s'estompe
même son de cloche du côté du modem si
les deux courts on s'associe personne
n'a de visée hégémonique
il ya une volonté de travailler ensemble
alors quand on a une volonté de
travailler ensemble
on cherche pas comme ça à prendre le
dessus on sait simplement qu'il faut se
respecter les uns les autres
faut respecter les identités des uns et
des autres on a des histoires séparées
on a oui les nuances et on a envie de
surmonter cela et de faire en sorte que
et bien cette addition de différence
face une force nouvelle
le rapport de force a bien changé en
moins d'un an lui d y marquent le tempo
désormais au centre tant le modem compte
une vingtaine de parlementaires lui d y
en a trois fois plus quand j'imagine que
le sort des centristes vous intéresse
donc est ce que votre avis ce mariage va
fonctionner écoutez voilà des personnes
qui partagent des convictions communes
que je partage très largement également
les centres à l'ump on voit là il y à
des centristes nombreux à l'ump
conduits par des personnalités comme
jean pierre raffarin ou monsieur
leonetti il y a même s'il est radical il
y a une seule commun et ce socle c'est
l'humanisme c'est l'europe qui va être
un sujet d'actualité du fait des
élections c'est aussi l'élection
alors disons que les élections mettent
en lumière le besoin d'un projet
européen
et puis c'est aussi une vision de la
société moi j'ai en charge à strasbourg
j'ai très bien travaillé avec jean louis
borloo sur la rénovation urbaine la
dignité retrouvée
pour les habitants du quartier
concrètement est ce que vous voyez
françois bayrou faire une opr sur lui et
je crois qu'il se retrouve jean louis
borloo et françois bayrou ils se
connaissent donc de bois fabienne keller
je crois que françois bayrou est revenu
à un certain réalisme et ils voient bien
que gouvernement qui l'a donc il a
soutenu l'élection il a soutenu françois
hollande est très désespérant pour la
france et pour les français et ce que
vous croyez vraiment à une recomposition
du ce
est ce qu'il ya vraiment une place pour
le centre quand on voit un front
national aussi fort en tout cas comme le
disent les sondages qui a vraiment sa
place
alors pour ma part je suis centriste au
sein de l'ump et j'ai fait le choix de
faire vivre cette sensibilité au sein
d'un mouvement fédérateur qui rassemble
des personnes qui ont des sensibilités
qui peuvent être un peu différente
il y a une force centriste qui est en
train de s'organiser et là elle a sa
place mais je m'en sens évidemment très
proches alors fabienne keller mardi
c'est une question de rythme à
l'assemblée l'ump en a fait son angle
d'attaqué avant les municipales le parti
a diffusé un tract à un million
d'exemplaires pour demander le report de
la réforme fillon sur les rythmes
scolaires jugé injuste mal préparée et
mal financée à l'assemblée jean françois
copé a interpellé le ministre écoute et
vous avez décidé cette réforme des
rythmes scolaires en catimini par décret
les enfants
monsieur le ministre nous en avons tous
les témoignages les enfants sont épuisés
par l'augmentation du temps scolaire ça
ne peut pas être en augmentant les
impôts locaux alors que vous avez
matraquer les français comme vous l'avez
fait part des impôts d'état que vous
trouverez la solution
je vous demande donc de reporter cette
réforme avant que la colère du peuple de
france ne vous oblige à démissionner
réformes que nous menons y compris avec
des élus de votre bord politique elle et
puis quand il vous plait côté permettre
à chacun de se dépasser
car nous savons en effet que lorsque
l'école de la france marchera mieux
alors c'est l'ensemble du pays qui
marchera mieux nous vous attendons à ce
rendez vous on a compris que vous avez
un rendez vous politique avec les
municipales faites attention ne pas
enfourcher ce cheval vous risquez de
tomber et la chute sera nouveau
l'arrière tout le monde semblait plutôt
assez d'accord notamment à l'ump avec
cette réforme n'est aujourd'hui tout le
monde est contre pourquoi ce brusque
changement de position a plutôt d'accord
ce n'est pas exact
si 2010 en augmentation attendez michèle
tabarot ump qui dit oui il faut changer
quatre jours quatre jours et demi
la question du rythme de vie des enfants
du fait qu'ils ont peu de jours de
classe par rapport aux 365 jours de
l'année est posée et un débat était très
largement ouvert par luc chatel le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est la solution qui a été
imposé par vincent peillon les quatre
jours et demi les quatre jours et demi
une réforme venu d'en présenter assez
tardivement et sans consulter les
centaines de milliers de personnes dont
il s'agit et qu'il faut accompagner je
ne parle pas des enfants là je suis sur
les professionnels les enseignants et
l'ensemble des acteurs du monde
associatif qui doivent animer les
séquences qui sont prévus pour
l'ouverture pour ce temps périscolaire
et puis les mairies qui sont priés de
tout organiser tout ça a été fait dans
la précipitation sans aucune prise en
compte de l'enfant
au fond le seul sujet ici ça devrait
être l'enfant son rythme est ce qu'on
lui propose en terminant même les
chronobiologistes les professeurs tout
le monde avait l'air de dire oui il faut
appliquer les quatre jours et demi donc
pourquoi aujourd'hui l'ump est vent
debout sur cette position alors que vous
l'aviez en 2010 tout le monde était
d'accord sur le fait que les enfants
n'avait pas un bon rythme
donc il fallait changer le rythme mais
pas n'importe comment mais comment alors
justement quelle qu'elle soit le bon
rythme pour c'est très fort je ne veux
pas prétendre être meilleur que les
grands spécialistes les chercheurs et
les enseignants et les parents d'élèves
impliqué c'est toutes ces personnes
chaque fois autour de chaque école qu'il
s'agit de mobiliser pour réfléchir
ensemble au bon rythme et aux bonnes
activités et ça ça se décrète pas et
puis il ya les problèmes d'argent c'est
un simple d'organisation ou de
financement avant tout c'est un brin de
réalité terrain et de vécu c'est un
problème très humain est ce qu'on
propose aux enfants plutôt des activités
culturelles des activités autour de
l'environnement du sport ou juste de la
garderie ce qui semble être le cas dans
certains endroits
recréant une inégalité que l'école
républicaine a permis de préserver
alors moi je suis à titre personnel un
produit de l'école républicaine donc
donner à chacun à chaque enfant les
mêmes
c'est pour moi non négociable et cette
réforme mal portait mal engagé qui n'a
pas pris le temps de sa mise en oeuvre
eh bien c'est ce de se prendre le risque
de casser ce pactole qui permet de
keller reste que c'est un thème très
porteur pour l'ump parce que là on parle
de la famille des enfants ça vous
rappelle pas un peu le débat sur les
mariages porté sur vous et en tactique
et j'essaye de vous répondre
autour de la question de la politicienne
aussi et donc je vous réponds et je vous
pose la question autour d'eux en tant
que politicienne dont on voit bien que
la forcément un lien rapport avec les
élections municipales vous pouvez pas le
cacher bien sûr nous sommes dans le
débat politique et le débat politique
il peut être fructueux nous avons six
mois de débats à l'occasion des
municipales
c'est le moment d'évoquer la prise en
compte de l'enfant puisque la prise en
charge des écoles
c'est une très belle mission des mairies
et que les maires les 36000 maires de
france s'y attelle avec beaucoup
d'engagement et notamment dans les
petites communes tiennent beaucoup à
leur école donc ré ouvrir un débat sur
la famille oui il est apparu au moment
du débat mariage pour tous mais il n'a
pas été poursuivi
la famille socle de la société mais
aussi remise en cause quand la moitié
des enfants naissent en dehors du
mariage donc quelles nouvelles formes
les familles qu'elles accompagnent ce
débat on va avancer un petit peu on va
passer au mercredi au jour du conseil
des ministres et françois hollande qui
recadre ses ministres alors après les
polémiques en série visiblement le
président de la république a voulu taper
du poing sur la table et faire preuve de
fermeté l'exécutif a même donné des
consignes très claires pour contrôler la
communication démoniste il faudra passer
par matignon les explications et un
dollar le ton semble bel et bien s'être
durci au dernier conseil des ministres
après la polémique valls duflot de la
semaine dernière aucun commentaire des
deux intéressés
un recadrage ce matin
c'est bien la porte parole du
gouvernement confirme pour sa part qu'il
ya bel et bien été question de recadrage
présent la république a rappelé aux
ministres les règles qu'ils doivent
respecter collégialité solidarité et que
s'il subsiste une dissension entre
ministres et bien doit être arbitrée en
interne par le président lui-même au
prochain quoique aurait averti le chef
de l'état ce sera la porte le message
audio aurait même été enregistré lors du
conseil des ministres histoire de
redresser la barre après une semaine
marquée par des critiques sur le manque
d'autorité de françois hollande confirmé
dans son rôle de grand coordinateur de
la parole gouvernementale jean marc
ayrault enfonce le clou
tant mieux qu'ils aient des
personnalités dans un gouvernement et
qu'elles soient diverses mais un
gouvernement ce n'est pas une addition
d'individualités
après avoir à deux reprises volé la
vedette à manuel valls lors des
questions au gouvernement
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur si le premier
ministre vient aujourd'hui vous laisser
répondre
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre mais cette marque de fermeté
est aussi un risque d'implosion alors
que le premier ministre laissait
entendre que manuel valls regretter ses
propos sur les roms
l'entourage du ministre de l'intérieur
dément telle information hier soir la
nouvelle ligne gouvernementale
s'appliquera-t-elle aussi aux proches
des ministres une autre polémique agite
déjà la toile un tweet de xavier cantat
compagnon de cécile duflot justement
consacré à cette question du recadrage
fabienne keller qui recadrait dans cette
histoire le premier ministre chargé de
tenir ses troupes ou les ministres c'est
l'image catastrophique d'un gouvernement
qui gère des égouts et pas de projet pas
de volonté de travailler en équipe
quand je vois christiane taubira et
manuel valls développer une polémique
par médias interposés sur le sujet
tellement essentiel pour nos concitoyens
qu'est la sécurité
moi je dis c'est inadmissible ils ont
chacun un domaine en charge mais ils ont
tout autant la responsabilité de
travailler ensemble pour se coordonner
les policiers
acteurs du monde de la justice ces deux
piliers de la sécurité de l' assurance
de l'application des lois pour tous les
français ils doivent se mettre d'accord
et si les ondes et les bas ils doivent
être entre eux et en amont et pas devant
les français alors sur la sur la méthode
employée de la méthode de recadrage est
ce que cette ligne de code est intenable
et ce qu'il faudrait pas aussi cornaquer
contrôler les conjoints qui est l'envoi
des tweets à la réfection du chalet
collabos on est maître d'école c'est
grave qu'ils doivent en arriver là a
tapé avec une règle sur le bout des
doigts de chacun
c'est pas comme ça qu'on peut construire
un projet pour la france il faut une
vision partagée et que chacun déploie
toute son énergie et toute sa compétence
il ya la jurisprudence delphine batho
ils sont tous paralysés dans leurs
actions
là où l'état de la france au contraire
imposerait d'avoir des personnalités
fortes
volontaire et portant un but d'un projet
par cette salle pour la société qui a
peut-être trop de personnalités fortes
dans ce gouvernement il faut des
personnalités fortes pour redresser la
france mais des personnalités fortes qui
travaillent ensemble aujourd'hui au rien
ne peut s'organiser sans que plusieurs
ministères travaillent ensemble
aujourd'hui sont incapables de le faire
c'est absolument dramatique
et au passage par différence on voit que
françois fillon a fait un formidable
travail de coordination du gouvernement
des couacs au sol et je dois dire qu'au
niveau local c'est la même réalité dans
ma ville comme strasbourg
aujourd'hui monsieur rice a beaucoup de
mal avec ses adjoints
eh bien ça fait que la ville est moins
puissante et arrive mans à agir
concrètement ou service des habitants
et quelque part les élus perdent un peu
l'objectif de leur mission qui est de
servir qui est de s'occuper des gens des
élus qui agissent avec plus de
transparence en tout cas c'est le mot
d'ordre à l'assemblée au palais bourbon
le veau d'or de claude bartolone le
président de l'assemblée a présenté le
bilan d'un an de législature d'elodie
mieux encadrer plus de contrôle sur
l'utilisation de la fameuse réserve
parlementaire écouter le président de
l'assemblée il y un an je m'engageais à
ce que le voile soit levé et l'arbitré
rompue en ce qui concerne la réserve
parlementaire
parole tenue nous avons changé la règle
du jeu en faveur de plus d'équité
dorénavant un député de l'opposition
dispose d'autant de crédit qu un député
de la majorité de plus de transparence
l'assemblée nationale publiera en fin
d'année l'utilisation qui en a été fait
par chaque député
il y un an je m'engageais à réglementer
l'activité des représentants d'intérêts
à l'assemblée nationale parole tenue le
27 février 2013
monsieur christophe sirugue vice
président de l'assemblée nationale a
remis un rapport sur le lobbying à
l'assemblée plusieurs des
recommandations de ce rapport sont
entrées en application y est est-ce que
sur ces questions fabienne keller les
lobbys la réserve parlementaire donc le
contrôle finalement de l'exécutif
l'assemblée aujourd'hui à un temps
d'avancé sur le sénat le sida est assez
performant aussi des exemples peut-être
sur le fond moi je crois que vraiment
les temps ont changé l'exigence de nos
concitoyens est forte et donc moi je
suis favorable à la transparence le
sénat joue le jeu de la transparence lui
aussi écoutez moi je peux vous dire qu'à
titre personnel j'ai publié et
l'ensemble des éléments de ma
rémunération non patrimoine
l'utilisation de la réserve
parlementaire et l'utilisation des frais
parlementaires sur mon site internet
ça me semble comment dire une
orientation peut-être que nous inspirent
les nordiques les suédois les danois et
qui va dans le sens d'une confiance
qu'il nous faut reconstruire avec nos
concitoyens
il se méfie de tout ce qui est caché
donc au delà des contrôles évoquée par
le président de l'assemblée nationale
à l'instant je pense que c'est la
transparence dire les choses dire ce
qu'on fait il est dit aussi a beaucoup
parlé des contrôles de la loi il va
lancer plusieurs missions d'information
notamment pour voir où en est la loi
aujourd'hui
ça s'applique c'est bien ce qu'il fait
c'est c'est plutôt juste pour le rôle
des parlementaires je serai bientôt
évidemment le sénat le fait depuis très
longtemps et à titre personnel j'ai fait
beaucoup de contrôles d'application de
la loi j'ai longtemps eu en charge le
budget de l'environnement j'ai fait des
contrôles sur l'application des
directives européennes et c'est
passionnant et cela permet de relier
leurs livres c'est quoi l'idée qu'on
applique vraiment là ou pas et bien
qu'on ne met pas toujours les moyens
budgétaires nécessaires à différents
niveaux
qui dit aussi des responsabilités
partagées exemple sur la qualité de
l'eau il faut travailler avec les
syndicats locaux intercommunaux qui gère
l'eau comme avec les préfectures avec le
niveau national et appliquer les
directives européennes
donc il faut pas être dans le rejet de
responsabilité il faut être dans le
travail ensemble
est ce que vous direz que les lobbys
aujourd'hui sont mieux encadrer ces
mêmes lobby qui ont une influence forte
sur la rédaction de certains articles
sur la rédaction certaine que j'ai envie
de vous dire qu'on n'est pas du tout
dans un système à l'américaine
aujourd'hui en france donc les lobbys ne
nous faisons pas trop peur voilà moins
loin que parlement européen tout à fait
globalement que le monde anglo saxon
mais néanmoins mêmes règles la
transparence dire les choses si des
personnes qui représentent un lobby
pénètre dans nos commissions dans nos
murs
faisons le savoir pour que tout le monde
en soit conscient je dis ça vienne
keller la constitution française fête
ses 55 ans de nombreux ministres et ex
ministre de la vème république étaient
présents pour célébrer l'événement
françois hollande a aussi saisi
l'occasion de cet anniversaire pour
faire une annonce pas de révision
constitutionnelle ni de 6ème république
mais un appel à l'arbitrage du peuple
la révision constitutionnelle de 2008
avait prévu le référendum d'initiative
populaire
la loi organique permettant
l'application de cette mesure n'a
toujours pas été adopté j'ai demandé au
gouvernement de soumettre un projet au
parlement avant la fin de l'année
alors ce référendum d'initiative
populaire c'était donc une grande
promesse de nicolas sarkozy finalement
c'est françois hollande qui qui annonce
qui va la mettre en oeuvre est ce qu'il
n'a pas fait marche arrière par peur de
voir instaurer la un contre pouvoir vous
parler de sarkozy je parle de nicolas
sarkozy moi je j'ai envie de faire la
lecture à peu près un vrai ça c'est
françois hollande qui ceux qui chassent
les pantoufles de nicolas sarkozy pour
enfin prendre une mesure forte et
symbolique
il a tant de mal à en construire
lui-même sur l'emploi sur des sujets de
société a pour une fois une proposition
de loi qui fait consensus
et oui bah oui mais c'est celle de sarko
c'est comme ça c'est celle du précédent
gouvernement et la précédente majorité
ce qui n'est toujours pas en vigueur
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui s'est fait
et franchement techniquement je n'ai pas
la réponse c'est une bonne chose c'était
une conviction forte du précédent
président il souhaitait pouvoir donner
la parole au peuple
alors il faut il faut s'assurer que
voilà mais les autres le parlement ne
sont pas des saisies de leurs
responsables et reste précise quand même
trouvé un bon équilibre
à l'image de ce qui existe au niveau
européen aussi où le parlement peut être
interpellé 6 1 millions au moins de
citoyens européens l'exigent si jamais
aujourd'hui il y avait un référendum
quel serait pour vous en tout cas la
question qu'il faudrait poser en
priorité aux français
alors oui question piège il faut faire
bon usage du référendum puisque les
français ne répondent pas toujours à la
question posée comme on l'a vu sur le
référendum européen cela constitue ce
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure la rive
moi je ne suis pas sûr vous voyez mes
priorités soit de cliver c'est-à-dire de
séparer entre les français qui dirait
oui et qui dirait non à une question
trop simple ce n'est pas dur à trouver
c'est le but oui mais moi qui vais
beaucoup à la rencontre des
strasbourgeois en l'occurrence depuis de
nombreux mois
j'ai plutôt envie de dire que les
français ont envie de dialogue de débat
sur les questions évoquées tout à
l'heure comme la famille sur comment on
pourrait redémarrer la france en est
exempte strasbourg si vous deviez faire
un référendum de basse après sur quoi
écouter sur quelque chose peut-être sur
l'enfant sur sur le vivre ensemble sur
l'éducation sur sur ce que ce qui fait
ciment mais à nouveau plus qu'un
référendum avec une question simple
hyper simplifiée plutôt un vaste débat
qui permet de d'exprimer la richesse
l'un d'eux ce que sont les engagements
des français et leur conjonction de
démocratie participative plus de
dialogue avec le terrain oui et au delà
la démocratie et du dialogue de l'action
moi je ressens que si la france comme ma
ville s'en sortiront c'est grâce à des
entrepreneurs qui agiront des personnes
qui s'engageront dans leur assaut ce
dans leur école dans leur trajet lettre
mot de votre votre campagne c'est ce que
vous essayez de mettre en oeuvre pour
votre contact pense que c'est c'est
comme cela aussi que nous pourrons
réconcilier la politique et des citoyens
en construisant des projets avec e.on
laissant à chacun sa liberté mais en les
épaulant c'est ça le l'action publique
fabienne keller vous êtes vice
présidente de la commission des finances
vous avez vu est certainement passer le
nombre est évidemment très important de
projets de loi sur sur la finance il y
aura bientôt ce projet qui arrive en
commission en tout cas la semaine
prochaine à l'assemblée des élus ump ont
mené cette semaine une offensive ils ont
présenté ce qu'on va appeler un contre
budget très buffard charleville
baisser les dépenses plutôt qu'augmenter
les impôts c'est le principe sur lequel
l'ump dit s'appuyer pour bâtir son
budget les députés de l'opposition
voudraient annuler certaines hausse
estimée à près de cinq milliards d'euros
via celle qui massacrent un peu le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages donc je
pense par exemple au quotient familial
qui est raboté d'année en année par le
gouvernement et puis sur les entreprises
il ya des paradoxes complet il ya une
contradiction totale d'un côté on dit
qu'il faut la compétitivité de l'autre
on va augmenter les impôts des
entreprises dans le viseur de
l'opposition notamment la création de la
taxe sur l'excédent brut d'exploitation
des entreprises pour financer ces
baisses d'impôts l'opposition veut
réduire les dépenses
elle propose de rétablir certaines
réformes mises en place par le
gouvernement de françois fillon comme la
révision générale des politiques
publiques ou le jour de carence dans la
fonction publique
autre priorité pour l'ump réduire le
nombre de fonctionnaires dans l'immédiat
les économies les plus importants sont à
attendre de la masse salariale des
fonctions publiques en incluant dans
cette masse salariale également les
retraites
là c'est un enjeu de plusieurs centaines
de milliards d'aud lui md propose aussi
de tailler dans les dépenses sociales
avec notamment l'attribution des aides
au logement selon des critères sociaux
pour les étudiants ou la restriction du
nombre de bénéficiaires de la prime pour
l'emploi et la valeur à cette question
sociale que j'ai envie de vous poser la
première question
parmi les pistes avancées par l'ump la
prime pour l'emploi uniquement pour les
plus modestes c'est juste alors les
dispositifs de compensation au chômage
ou d'accompagnement du retour à l'emploi
sont devenues très compliquées et l'idée
de les regrouper pour les clarifier et
pour clairement avoir un objectif simple
qui est de permettre une meilleure
rémunération pour ceux qui travaillent
même si c'est à temps partiel même si
c'est un cdd vont dans le bon sens pour
vous c'est juste ça
bon sens là le l'important est dans le
détail
l'idée c'est de regrouper ces aides pour
qu'ils aillent dans le sens de la prime
à celui qui bosse c'est un sujet
absolument stratégique
et il faut le savoir qu'il est différent
c'est ça qui nous différencie fortement
de l'allemagne c'est c'est papa d'asti
stade assez c'est plus compliqué que ça
c'est que aujourd'hui une personne qui
est aux minima sociaux et qui travaille
peut se trouver quand elle est à nouveau
en difficulté en situation de baisse de
revenus de baisse de couverture
notamment la cmu la couverture santé
et ça c'est inadmissible il faut avoir
une prime pour l'emploi qui est vraiment
ceux qui prétendraient ce jour social
exemple encore des propositions ump des
critères nationaux pour les prestations
handicap uniquement des critères
nationaux pouvoir alors le handicap est
un sujet très humain là aussi aux mains
des départements il faut sûrement
évaluer ce qui se passe dans les
départements pour qu'il y ait une équité
dans semble assurée sur le territoire
national mais je crois que ce soit des
critères qui permettent donc en
désaccord avec une partie des
propositions faites je vends car j'ai le
garage proposait le jeu propose d'avoir
une appréciation plus locale parce que
les aides aux handicapés
alors la personne handicapée c'est
quelque chose qui évolue dans le temps
qui prend en compte l'état de la
personne c'est pas quelque chose qui se
prête aux critères même s'ils sont
nombreux sur la philosophie générale de
ce contre budget est ce qu'un projet de
loi de finances comme ça sans hausse
d'impôts c'est réaliste alors que est ce
que la france peut vraiment se le
permettre alors que dans tous les pays
d'europe on est obligé quand même
d'augmenter les impôts alors hein je
trouve très courageux de la part de
gilles carez de faire ces propositions
sont pas évident de faire des
propositions au d'économies je reconnais
bien là son sens de la responsabilité
puis sa forte connaissance indue du
budget de l'état par ailleurs les impôts
augmentent très très fortement un seul
chiffre plus 12 milliards
euros sur l'impôt sur le revenu de 50
972 milliards entre 2012 et 2013
et d'ailleurs tous les français s'en
rendre compte nous recevrons tous en ce
moment nos impôts à payer quel est le
juste niveau puisqu'il faut bien en même
temps régler le problème de la dette
astronomique française que la dette est
astronomique progrès elle continue à
progresser elles représentent
aujourd'hui 97% du pib de la france donc
les mesures que propose le gouvernement
un pénalisent les français puisque la
fiscalité va encore augmenter l'année
prochaine sur l'impôt sur le revenu que
je citais ont fait 5 milliards de plus
donc ça va continuer à augmenter les
impôts locaux augmentent dans de
nombreuses l'île souvent socialiste donc
je disais le déficit ne se ne recule pas
donc toute la question c'est de faire
redémarrer la machine économique
parce que c'est celle qui produit des
cotisations sociales de l'impôt sur les
sociétés de l'emploi et du revenu pour
des millions de français alors fabi
lequel est rien comme des sujets qui
font qu'il faut consensus puisque la
majorité a apporté cette semaine ses
voix à l'opposition c'est un fait rare
ça se passait à l'assemblée la gauche a
voté pour la proposition de loi ump qui
vise à soutenir les petites librairies
indépendantes le prix d'un livre acheté
en ligne ne pourra plus être inférieur
de 5%
toute réduction confondues message à
destination du géant amazon est ce que
pour vous cette proposition de loi va
vraiment dissuader des géants du livre
comme du livre en ligne comme amazon de
pratiquer c'est cette concurrence
je veux vous dire je veux témoigner que
des petites librairies dans les
quartiers de strasbourg apporte un plus
en proximité pour les enfants les jeunes
du quartier pour qu'ils puissent voilà
choisir facilement un ouvrage en terme
d'animation parce qu'ils font venir
quelqu'un qui dédicace à un ouvrage donc
tout tout geste qui permet de tenter de
préserver cette vision très très
européenne
française du commerce de proximité du de
la vie un pardon intellectuelle de
l'animation à travers une activité
économique qui est le commerce du
libraire va dans le bon sens
est-ce que ça va empêcher le géant
d'internet et c'est pas sûr mais
j'observe qu'aujourd'hui nos concitoyens
cherche aussi le contact
nous en avons tous les mares de tapoter
sur des machines pour chercher un ticket
de transport pour commander un billet de
train pour sert tous les actes de la vie
et qu'on recherche cette qualité de
relation il faut bien pouvoir pour
préserver ce modèle économique c'était
vrai mais y est habilité à signer ce 16e
de prix ou c ou abandonnés parce que
amazon a répondu en disant que
finalement c'est le consommateur qui va
au final être pénalisés parce qu'il
devra payer plus cher alors le
consommateur peut faire son choix
d'abord et puis il faut je crois que sur
les sujets culturels et intellectuels
il faut veiller à préserver notre
patrimoine nos traditions ce qui fait la
richesse aussi peut-être de la france ce
qui fait que les touristes viennent
nombreux par rapport à d'autres pays
cet art de vivre cette capacité à
débattre réfléchir bas c'est aussi grâce
à la diffusion du livre mais aussi des
vidéos mais aussi les éleveurs et télé
je fais la liaison vous avez peut-être
vu en tout cas les deux séries un peu à
ses phares en ce moment sur nos télés et
sur nos ordinateurs fabienne keller
c'est notre plus de l'hebdo alors quel
est le rapport entre la série danoise
borgen dont arte diffuse la troisième
saison et la série française les hommes
de l'ombre à tout simplement les femmes
en politique c'est timo barbarie qui
nous explique tout ça quand les séries
s'emparent du pouvoir
c'est sous les traits d'une femme qu'il
s'incarne à l'image de borgen le
désormais incontournable feuilleton
danois la troisième et ultime saison de
cette fiction politique est actuellement
sur nos écrans
l'héroïne birgit nyborg ancien premier
ministre du danemark prépare dans ce
dernier volet son come back en politique
le personnage est une combattante avec
des convictions des vrais
mais n'est pas prête à tout pour les
faire triompher en tout cas je ne
foulerait pas au pied des principes
fondamentaux simplement pour laisser mon
empreinte sur un l'accord économique
tout à fait insignifiant en méprisant
les droits de l'homme qui sont pour le
parti centriste
l'axé principal de sa politique est une
de ses priorités pas de cynisme ne met
pas d'angélisme non plus dans cette
description au cordeau de la démocratie
moderne
l'action est ici réduite à son minimum
et se concentrent dans l'alternance des
scènes intimes et public
merki tu tu n'étais jamais là tu bosses
et 24 heures sur 24 ça me colle éphrem
ça ne pouvait évidemment pas coller flip
revenait de me nommer premier ministre
changement de décor et de styles avec la
série française les hommes de l'ombre
sorti en début d'année cette fois ci
aussi les femmes sont au coeur du
pouvoir
le personnage de nathalie baye sera même
dans la course à l'élection
présidentielle bat la différence de
morgen l'intriguent privilégie le
terrain de la communication et a
tendance à délaisser celui des idées
l'accent est mis sur ces hommes de
l'ombre ces conseillers qui entoure les
dirigeants se représentent les david
dameuse
qui organisera la communication
d'attenté des lettres d'or c'est
officiel vous vous présenter alors qu'en
france moins de 30% de femmes sont
représentées au parlement
c'est à se demander si la fiction n'a
pas une fois encore un temps d'avancé
sur la réalité et nous accueillons dans
parlement hebdo d'anne frank bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
avez beaucoup écrit oeuvres littéraires
des clés pour le cinéma pour la
télévision
actuellement les hommes de l'ombre la
saison 2 est en tournage j'ai eu un gros
succès pour la saison 1 une question
simple pourquoi ce choix de des femmes
dans votre feuilleton pourquoi pourquoi
choisit d'avoir rectifié une petite
chose je suis un des créateurs de la
série est le créateur des personnages
mais je n'ai pas travaillé sur la
deuxième saison
voilà donc c'est la suite expliqué la
première montre donc on va parler
uniquement de la première c'est bien on
n'attend pas souvent posé la question de
savoir pourquoi une femme je dois dire
que je me la suis pas posé à moi même
venu je voulais absolument naturel en
jeu
voilà voilà il n'y a pas de raison
particulière sinon un centre la
démocratie qui fait que pourquoi pas une
femme pourquoi pas et je suis toujours
très étonnée qu'on me pose cette
question d'ailleurs ça veut bien dire
peut-être s'accroche un petit peu plus
aux téléspectateurs aussi bon c'était
non franchement non franchement non non
mais c'est étonnant qu'on pose des
questions ça veut dire que c'est pas du
tout entré dans les moeurs
dans les deux cas du cas la femme
politique vous dites
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on laisse
imaginer séquelles que ce soit dans borg
à nous les femmes de l'ombre
les anglais l'ont pas volé son propre
avec presque idéaliste c'est ça aussi
fabienne keller qui fait le succès de de
ces séries écoutez je crois qu'ils ont
touchées simplement les français et pour
moi c'est aussi quelque chose de très
beau après essayé de l'expliquer il faut
faire attention les femmes sont diverses
donc il faut pas attribuer des qualités
définitif mais je dois dire que moi je
ne m'identifie bien assez à ces deux
séries ont fait pas par des bribes
j'ai passé cette prétention président
dela depuis lors je n'ai pas cette
prétention moi j'aime bien le terrain le
local j'aime bien ma ville mais mais
voilà dès les éléments comme ceux
relatifs à la vie très personnel qui
temps en temps télescope
c'est sa vie d'élu et ses choix d'élus
c'est quelque chose que nous vivons et
voilà le voir un film quelque part c'est
quelque chose de très fort le rôle de
nathalie baye je les écris comme ça sert
je me suis dit qu'elle était plutôt à
ses novices en matière de politique bien
qu'ayant des jeunes carrière politique
mais enfin elle n'a pas eu des postes
fondamentaux comme ça mais on n'a pas
pensé elle au départ pour l'élection
présidentielle
mais ce sont ses qualités de huy
humaines hors appareils surtout dans les
appareils c'est quand même quelque chose
de terrible tout à l'heure pardonnez moi
mais je vous écoute et il confié
franchement jeu par exemple je me
demandais comment est ce que vous
pouviez défendre aujourd'hui une loi sur
les quatre jours et demi alors qu'en
fait tout les chronobiologistes tout le
monde dans l'éducation considération
tout le monde considère que c'est une
erreur et je me dis comment est-ce que
alors que à l'époque
à l'époque tous enfin il y avait un
consensus pour dire qu'il fallait penser
d'abord à l'enfant et je me dis
aujourd'hui on est dans un système
politique tel que on est dans une cour
de récréation c'est certain qu'on de
récréation peut-être d'accord par les
services et des postures là où on
devrait effectivement je parlais de
l'enfant et de la recherche de rythme en
ce que je voulais dire c'est que je
trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de postures
parfois dans
le cheminement politique et que ce que
moi j'ai voulu montrer dans les hommes
de l'ombre c'est justement un personnage
un personnage qu'il est qui était au
contraire et que des pilules libre mais
évidemment il ya tout ce qui se passe
autour et on va le relever communicants
et de tous ceux qui gravitent autour du
personnage politique centralement arrive
c'est ça aussi fabienne keller j'avais
certainement constaté mais on peut
rester très humain nous on est quand
même dans un système qui est qui a ses
règles et sa dureté
donc si on veut aussi pouvoir avancer il
faut le comprendre mais pas forcément
s'y plier c'est tout le défi en tout cas
de rennes des communiqués à changer
complètement le paysage politique
dire que avant la guerre vous aviez des
hommes des politiques qui étaient
peut-être entouré de personnages qui
s'occupait de leur image mais c'était
souvent des militants politiques s quand
vous parlons jeu et ses dérivés la
communication a changé a tout changé se
dire que maintenant on gouverne beaucoup
aux sondages à ce qui plaît ce qui plaît
pas regardé par exemple la polémique
duflot valls est absolument
extraordinaire c'est à dire qu'en fait
on la juge en fonction des sondages et
non pas de la réalité ou de la
profondeur du sujet et c'est pourquoi je
suis en fait en vérité à ses critiques à
l'égard des communicants politiques
voilà de quoi peut-être faire encore une
nouvelle série comme cette faille sur
les 1 0 mais peut-être une prochaine
location n'est pas seulement descendante
grâce aux réseaux sociaux
elle peut permettre aussi une expression
plus directe et si elle touche
elle fait alors elle fait écho comme
votre film simone estran savais pas que
communiquer autour de lui quoi et
c'était un homme de conviction général
de gaulle non plus d'ailleurs se prendre
deux exemples
je vais peut-être dire que je fais un
rêve c'est de rivère réconcilier un peu
sur le terrain les français la politique
la fiction peut donner à une autre image
de bien
merci à vous voici le programme à la
semaine prochaine